so we have basically fashion everywhere
in both sides of the unit this is the
epicentre of the usa's battle with the
delta variant
if proof were needed of the
effectiveness of vaccines
they lay in this coved unit hooked up to
machines struggling to breathe
debbie the nurse manager can't believe
they're in this position again
only this time it's worse and with more
than 95
of these patients unvaccinated it feels
avoidable
you've gone from having two covered
patients to having
hundreds in the space of how long two
and a half weeks
it's all just start so all the changes
everything just start
our icu better full you know we're
taking care of five six patients at one
time that's not an easy task
so to see that people still kind of like
in denial and don't think the vaccine
can help
or even don't put the mask because you
know it's not
mandatory it's really upsetting florida
accounts for six percent of the u.s
population
but 20 of the current coronavirus cases
it also has one of the lowest
vaccination rates in the country
rooms here that should be for one
patient are now shared
they're also younger than before hey mr
johnson
how you doing
lawrence johnson has been here for 22
days
infected first by misinformation around
vaccines
now infected by the virus itself why did
you not have the vaccine
because every time you turn around you
hear all
different kind of stories and stuff and
you get scared and confused
it is best to have it
and don't need it then i don't have it
and neither
i am a living witness and i got a
vaccination
i wouldn't be here right now they're not
just fighting the virus in florida
there's a culture war raging on mass
squaring
these parents want masks to be mandatory
when schools in jacksonville return
after the summer holidays next week
but the state governor says that's not
going to happen despite the surge in
cases
this pediatric doctor is concerned about
the long-term effects of kovid
but kids do get sick and they do get
hospitalized and they do die
and the long-term complications of code
in children we are seeing those
if i get covered infection unfortunately
i may get long covered i may have if i'm
lucky to deal with it for 10 years 20
years
a 5 year old child may have to deal with
for 80 years
here they pray for the patients and the
nurses
knowing that this situation is likely to
get worse before it gets better again
martha kellner sky news jacksonville